[Music]
this is eight news now in today's eight
on your side if you're booking flights
for Christmas or New Year's and want to
avoid delays and cancellations our
flight expert weighs in on what type of
flight you should book and what number
to call if your flight gets canceled
whether it's extreme winds thunder
showers rain or snow severe weather can
really put a damper on our traveling
plans if you're concerned about your
flight getting disrupted there are a few
things you can do to put yourself in as
good of a position as possible Scott
Keyes of Scott's cheap flights says book
an early morning flight they depart on
time more consistently than afternoon or
evening flights the aircraft that you're
going to be flying for that early
morning flight it's already parked at
the airport it's there waiting for you
whereas for the afternoon and evening
flight that aircraft has to fly in and
if that flight gets canceled or delayed
then your flight is at risk prioritize
non-stop over connecting flights as Kai
says one out of every four flights gets
delayed you've got a non-stop flight a
two-hour delay just means you know it's
annoying but it means you're going to
get to your final destination two hours
late but a two-hour delay if you have a
connecting flight might mean that you
actually miss that connection and
considering how full flights are
nowadays it could be a while until
you're put on a a replacement flight now
if your flight is canceled don't stand
in line at the airport for hours don't
even call the airline's main hotline
it's actually to call the airlines
international phone lines you know
American Airlines doesn't just have
their main U.S hotline they've got
numbers in Mexico and the United Kingdom
in Japan and Singapore and Australia and
you can call any one of those numbers
and likely get through to an agent far
quicker than if you were to call the
main U.S hotline which everybody else is
calling especially if there's bad
weather and causing a lot of
cancellations
if your flight is canceled you are
entitled to a refund under the
Department of Transportation regulations
even if you've purchased non-refundable
airline tickets but be prepared for
hassles and be patient